[Music]
happy birthday mr. adult man
Omaha flaca gross what was dad like as
beardless Scratchy
he had a goofy laugh I wish I'd bet him
I have something for you
from your dad it's a wizard staff
I wrote this spell so I can see for
myself who my boys grew up to be
the spell brings him back back way back
to life you wanted to beat you more than
anything to to say doc I don't know it
just started
dad oh don't apart dad you are in your
house
[Music]
we've only got 24 hours to bring back
the rest of dad we're going on a quest
all quests start with the manticore the
fearless adventurer you mean
Cori she's over there that's the
manticore
get in the vehicle on escort yo I'm
giving you to the count of three okay
wait what are you doing I don't know I'm
looking for my sons
oh they went on a quest but don't worry
I told him about the map I told them
about the gym I told him about the curse
huh I forgot to tell about the card what
your boys are in grave danger
[Applause]
how do your boys do what a crisis Oh No
dead dead reject not great
I can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this I'm cleaning you
my gut knows where to go don't you boy
yes aru
on my way boys just
[Music]
[Music]